nos dicen que contemos por decenas y
decimos 1020 espacio 40 50 60 70 80 90
100 cuál es el número que falta pausa en
el vídeo cuál es el número que nos falta
aquí bueno si estamos contando por
decenas
decimos 10 20 30 40 50 60 70 80 90 100
así que nos falta el 30 cuál respuesta
tiene el 30 la tenemos aquí esta es
nuestra respuesta hagamos otro ejemplo
aquí nos preguntan cuáles bloques de
decenas representan 20 un bloque de
decena es una manera elegante para
identificar estos bloques o grupos que
contienen 10 objetos lo pueden ver justo
aquí 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 entonces
cuáles bloques de decenas representan 20
bueno 20 es igual a 2 grupos de 10 éste
tiene 10
tenemos 20 justo aquí la opción b es 10
20 30 40 la opción c es 10 20 30 así que
pueden sentirse bien de haber escogido
la opcional
aquí nos dicen que arrastremos los
bloques de decenas al recuadro para
tener 40 vamos a ver aquí tenemos 10
luego tenemos otros 10 que nos dan 20
después otros 10 ahora tenemos 30 y
finalmente otros 10 para tener 40 10 20
30 40 terminamos